SUBJECT: This is the largest
movable structure ever built.
It's taller than the
Statue of Liberty,
longer than two jumbo jets, and
nearly three times the weight
of the Eiffel Tower.
This mega structure is
the engineering feat
of an architect's dreams.
And beneath it is a
radioactive nightmare.
In 1986, a surge of power
destroyed one of the reactors
at Chernobyl
nuclear power plant,
leaving behind a toxic disaster.
An extreme amount
of radiation was
leaking into the environment,
and by extreme amount,
I mean like 400 times more
than the radioactive fallout
that followed the atomic
blast in Hiroshima, Japan.
About 200 people were
hospitalized immediately.
More than two
dozen of them died.
And at least 150,000
nearby residents
were forced to
leave their homes.
At the time, the long-term
effects of the radiation
exposure were still unknown.
To make matters worse,
because of weather patterns,
radiation from the
Chernobyl disaster
spread across the region
and far into Western Europe.
And what remained at
the Chernobyl plant
was close to 200 tons of nuclear
fuel and radioactive elements
emitting lethal
amounts of radiation.
So engineers had
to act fast to keep
more radiation from spreading.
In an effort to contain
the power plant,
an army of workers known,
as the liquidators,
started constructing a tomb.
The liquidators
worked day and night
to contain the worst of the
radiation inside the reactor.
And then they built a
concrete steel sarcophagus
around the whole building.
It took 206 days, and more than
half a million liquidators, who
wore little to no protection.
The structure was only meant
to last 20 to 30 years.
And the tomb was never
successfully sealed,
so there was no
way to protect it
from the corrosion and
environmental damage that
happens with anything
that's outside.
If the structure
were to collapse,
it's believed that a
radioactive dust cloud would
be ejected into the atmosphere.
And that sort of fallout
would be devastating
not only for Ukraine and
the surrounding countries,
but potentially for
the entire planet.
To really understand how
devastating it could be,
we need to dive into
some nuclear physics.
Spent or used nuclear fuel, like
the kind inside the Chernobyl
plant, consists primarily
of uranium, plutonium,
fission products, and
minor transuranic elements.
Some of the most significant
fission products or radioactive
isotopes released during
the Chernobyl disaster
were Iodine-131,
Cesium-137, Strontium-90,
and Plutonium-241.
These isotopes can
take lifetimes to decay
and then be considered harmless.
The rate at which
they decay is measured
by their half-life,
which is the time it
takes for a
radioactive substance
to lose half its radioactivity.
Now Iodine-131 decays
in a matter of days.
And Cesium-137 and Strontium-90
have half lives about 30 years.
The real problem child
is Plutonium-241.
While this isotope has a
half-life of only 14 years,
the isotopes that are
formed during its decay
are terrifying.
It decays into
Americium-241, which has
a half-life of about 432 years.
And then Americium-241
breaks down
into Neptunium-237, an
incredibly stable isotope,
which sounds good, but it's bad.
It has a staggering half-life
of 2.14 million years.
Essentially, this means that
if the old structure covering
Chernobyl were to collapse,
our planet would probably never
recover from the fallout.
Since this would be an
international disaster,
it needed an
international solution.
So more than 40
different countries,
along with engineers,
architects, and financiers,
stepped in and contributed
to Plan B, B as in big,
really, really big.
The New Safe Confinement,
or NSC, as it's called,
is large enough to entomb the
old Chernobyl sarcophagus.
The massive arch is
made of multiple layers
of rustproof stainless
steel, and it's
designed to withstand
extreme temperatures and even
natural disasters.
The space between the
inner and outer cladding
is incredibly important.
It holds a complex
ventilation system
which regulates humidity,
temperature, and pressure.
And that will prevent corrosion
and keep radioactive dust
from escaping the structure.
One of the greatest
challenges was deciding
where to build this giant tomb.
Because of the radiation
leaking from the damaged plant,
the structure couldn't be
constructed directly over it.
So to keep workers safe, they
built the NSC in two halves
300 meters away from
the power plant.
And this is where the major
engineering feat comes in,
because the arch needed to
be moved over the reactor.
And moving a 35,000-ton
structure has never been done
before.
Each of the halves were
lifted at separate times
and moved onto
specialized rails.
Once they were
connected, the arch
then inched its
way very carefully
over the existing sarcophagus.
Now the challenge is to
seal this giant tomb, which
is expected to be
completed by late 2017.
And then remotely operated
cranes inside the arch
will begin dismantling the
unstable old sarcophagus.
The New Safe
Confinement is expected
to last at least
the next 100 years,
but damage from the Chernobyl
disaster is irreversible.
Today we're starting
to understand
the human cost of
nuclear fallout,
as cancer rates and
other health impairments
rise among people exposed
to Chernobyl's radiation.
While this feat of
engineering showed
what could be accomplished when
faced with one of the worst
disasters in human
history, capping
a radioactive catastrophe
is not a permanent solution.
Let's not forget those
radioactive isotopes will still
be decaying for millions
of years to come.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Once the original Chernobyl
sarcophagus is dismantled,
the radioactive waste will
be removed from the site.
To find out where
radioactive waste is stored,
check out this video.
Thanks for watching "Seeker."
Make sure to like and
subscribe for new videos.